Laser als kriegswaffen ähnlich wie in star wars filme und das us militär entwickelt tatsächlich kampfflugzeuge die mit einem laser system
Ausgestattet sind das soll dann ihre piloten
Im ernstfall von drohnen und raketen schützen sehkraft die ersten tests in der luft sollen schon in vier jahren stattfinden
Wie das technisch funktionieren soll und vor welchen konsequenzen jetzt kritiker waren das jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Directed energy also
zielgerichtet der energie so werden laserwaffen
im militärischen sprachgebrauch genannt laser sind mittlerweile tatsächlich technisch soweit
Weiterentwickelt dass das militär große hoffnung in sie setzt jetzt hat die amerikanische
rüstungsfirma loket martin bekannt gegeben dass an einem ganz konkreten
Lasersystem geforscht wird und zwar, im auftrag der us airforce genaugenommen seiner forschungsabteilung dem airforce research lab
Frl nach angaben der rüstungsfirma soll die us airforce dafür
26,3 millionen us dollar also umgerechnet
22,6 millionen euro locker gemacht haben der konkrete auftrag die entwicklung eines
lasersystems für flugzeuge
das bereits in vier jahren in der praxis getestet
Werden könnte das projekt heißt lance und das steht für laser at once menz von next generation
compact environments übersetzt also in etwa leser entwicklung für kompakte
einsatzmittel der nächsten generation und jetzt ein mögliches szenario
Der kampfjet pilot plötzlich eine flugabwehrrakete die auf ihn zu gast die erste reaktion ganz klar ausweichen doch die rakete
explodiert die bedrohung ist ausgeschaltet denn der pilot hat einen laserstrahl
Abgefeuert von einer kanone an bord seines kampfjets das wäre dann
Also demnächst tatsächlich möglich offiziell so heißt es von seiten der rüstungsfirma sollen die leser waffen zur selbstverteidigung
Beitragen der us rüstungskonzern hatte bereits in den vergangenen jahren so laserwaffen geforscht
2014 hatten sie mit einem 10 kilowatt faserlaser ein schlauchboot versenkt und zwar auf einer entfernung von etwa
1,6 kilometern in einem versuch vor zwei jahren zerstört die die energie eines lesers die motorhaube eines
kleinlasters jetzt sollen die leser so klein und leicht werden dass sie eben auch an
kampfflugzeugen befestigt werden können einen 60 kilowatt laser der auf ein fahrzeug montiert werden kann wurde bereits in diesem jahr an die us
armee ausgeliefert einer der verantwortlichen von lockheed martin
rupp afzal bezeichnet den plan ein leser waffensystem auf einem flugzeug zu installieren als eine
völlig neue und andere herausforderung und weiter die entwicklung von hochleistungs
lasersystemen zeigt das laser waffensysteme real werden die technik ist so weit dass sie gebaut getestet und in flugzeugen
Fahrzeugen oder auf schiffen eingesetzt werden kann dass es überhaupt
So weit kommen kann und leser auch für das militär höchst interessant sind liegt an ihrer technischen weiterentwicklung für kampfjets geplant sind sogenannte
faserlaser also
Festkörperlaser die aus einer glasfaser bestehen und eine metall der seltenen erden wie neodym
Oder erbium die laserstrahlung wird verstärkt durch die länge der faser diese kann allerdings aufgewickelt werden
So dass sie nicht viel platz wegnimmt für im betrieb braucht es strom der laut militär
forschungsteams ganz leicht durch batterien bereitgestellt werden kann ältere leser brauchen einen gas oder ein kristall als medium dadurch werden die
lichtwellen verstärkt zudem gibt es eine
Genau justierte optik aus spiegeln und ihr könnt es euch vorstellen das ist viel zu anfällig um es beispielsweise in flugzeugen einzusetzen
Durch die neue technik ist das us rüstungsunternehmen optimistisch schon bald erste tests mit laserwaffen in der luft zu machen
2021 soll das der fall sein es gibt allerdings auch experten und expertinnen die da skeptischer sind der us-kongress
beispielsweise schreibt in einem bericht von diesem herbst dass es bereits noch viele technische
aspekte gibt die in sachen laserwaffen noch nicht ausgereift seien auch die us-marine und das
us-verteidigungsministerium forschen zu laserwaffen die forschungsagentur, des
us-verteidigungsministeriums plant ein system mit einem elektrischen leser mit dem von flugzeugen aus
bodenziele bekämpft werden sollen klingt alles irgendwie nach star wars aber bei all diesen plänen darf die ungeheure macht der strahlen waffen nicht
Unterschätzt werden nicht umsonst ist der einsatz von anti personen lesern
international geächtet und zwar in einer un konvention
das völkerrechtliche rahmenabkommen der vereinten nationen heißt sie dabei das ist die abkürzung für convention und politischen
restrictions on the use of certain conventional weapons
1998 trat das vierte protokoll in kraft das den einsatz blind machen da laserwaffen verbietet die betonung liegt auf einsatz
Denn die entwicklung und lagerung solcher waffen sind von dem verbot ausgenommen auch die federation of american scientists
in der sich zahlreiche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler organisiert
haben die hat eine warnung vor laserwaffen
ausgesprochen denn
Soldaten können beim einsatz sehr leicht erblinden ja wenn er kein video zum thema
Und auch, zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klicken die erste leser waffe der welt auf schiffen können leser nämlich schon
eingesetzt werden und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran